senator lindsey graham has authored a
bill to ban abortions nationwide 15
weeks after conception with very few
exceptions and that is a little more
liberal than what the the europeans do
now many have compared this to european
countries where generally there is a
minimum of 15 weeks but there's also
lots and lots of exceptions should we
look like iran and north korea
when it comes to national abortion
policy or maybe
france belgium germany spain denmark and
norway and of course many european
countries allow abortion after 15 weeks
not needing an exception many have
criticized this potential law as
hypocritical given the language around
states rights this would of course ban
abortion nationwide and take it out of
the state's hands this is where america
should be at the federal level and as
we've covered on this channel before
given the valence of the current supreme
court many people are worried that a
national ban would be held up as
constitutional by the supreme court but
a national right to abortion would not
be considered constitutional given the
political leanings of the current
justices